hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Arianna
glossary so we're checking out a special
cute video today cute video top ten cat
superpowers I'm thinking of getting a
cat
why so I wanted to what I'm sorry I
forget people are into cats
forget people are into Jewish girls well
they are yeah that's a thing when I was
in Catholic school I was really into
Jewish girls oh you were part of that
demographic I was yeah
top ten cats superpowers let's the do
this mean
[Applause]
[Music]
you don't want to get
Wow
[Music]
one of those little [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
I want to cat so bad why don't you like
cats their dim they don't let you hold
them they're not cuddly depending on the
cat you play you gotta catch my cat I
don't want to earn a cat's love wow you
just like things being given to you
don't you know okay I think kittens are
so cute okay they are very cute and
that's when they you say well like let
you hold them and touch them and play
with them but when they get older they
start running away and hiding
depending on how you raise the cat you
got a nurture it properly
got a cat prove it to me I will prove it
I want to be able to hold it and hug it
without it scratching me well you got a
light love and trust at first you know
cats can pick up on your emotions that's
one thing they didn't tell us in this
video that's gonna read you animals are
really good at reading behavior I like
dogs I'm like a dog person well dogs are
easy to earn their love yeah and then
when a dog like doesn't like humans
you're like what the fog run his dog but
when a cat loves a human it's like you
got the past the world I want a cat I
know cats up here having an animal helps
with positivity a lot they releases a
lot of positive endorphins good I need
right now if I get a cat I'm gonna so
feature that cat on this channel as much
as possible I got it I got that internet
people and everything's means the cat's
I got it mmm-hmm you kind of look like a
cat hey Jerry yeah I see a cat looking
her I wasn't cats in high school you can
see a cat look right she looks like a
cat kind of like a cat with tits right
anyway guys thanks for saying that was
out if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects Ariana has
just started up a YouTube channel videos
it's coming soon but you can subscribe
to it now and wait for them videos and
you can follow us on Facebook Instagram
and Twitter
where we're trying to get product
placement from condom companies who
really needs to know what a condom is I
she found out what it is for the first
time today before filming this video if
that was it's not none of this
because I've never been involved in
anything inappropriate like falling
apart believe them if you want but it's
not true it's molded that's disgusting
none of this is true doesn't have a
clitoris anymore so you make it's like
you never post these videos on my
Facebook is that like parents follow me
and they're gonna think I was a mess up
in China now